ouais
[Applaudissements]
et c'est la fin d'une carrière bien
remplie pour l'ex hervé décroche une
autre place 2e place une autre médaille
aujourd'hui à la coupe du monde à québec
dans quelques instants
il s'adresse aux médias nous diffuserons
son point de presse un directeur
alors voilà on écoute alex harvey qui a
mis faire sa carrière officiellement
aujourd'hui c'est si je fous pour moi le
défi comme soeur qui est vrai qu'avec
est finalement deux podiums ou mêmes
trous avec le temps de la journée
aujourd'hui est par navi finale la coupe
du monde parce que ça a été une saison
un peu rock'n'roll pour moi on se cache
pas un peu difficile avec est quand même
quelques déceptions ou dans les moments
clés des gens avec le tour de ski où
j'ai abandonné à deux étapes de la fin
survenu à la maison parce que j'avais pu
vraiment la tête à
à skier ou du moins à skier avec un dos
en sur les épaules
j'ai eu une bonne période de trois
semaines pour meurice été pour être
prêts à attaquer la deuxième moitié de
la vie de l'hiver puis finalement aux
mondiaux ben ça ça a été un peu mieux
quand même qu'autour de ski mais mais
pas à la hauteur de mes attentes de mes
espérances
c'est sûr que j'arrivais ici avec un
concept différent de ce que j'avais vécu
en 2010 c'est tout le jeu mais permet
les mondiaux je me battais pour eux le
cumulatif de la coupe du monde alors
c'est sûr que je rêvais à a peut-être
joué le podium mais c'était difficile
pour moi d'y croire pleinement mais
finalement déjà au vendredi c'est bien
parti avec une bonne bonne performance
en sprint mais samedi acheter jusqu'à
trouver royal avec la la foule qui m'ont
vraiment donné des ailes du monument
supporter puis elle aux bayards soir en
regardant le classement au cumulatif du
mini torche avec aujourd'hui ça ça
s'enligne pourrait peut-être une autre
des journées comme ça puis je voudrais
donc c'est sûr je vous remercier la
foule parce que je pense que ça sent les
milliers de personnes qui étaient là
présente durant tout le week-end à
partir de vendredi j'aurai probablement
pas pu skier comme ça parce que tout le
monde est fatigué en fin de saison puis
et puis moi c'est certain que j'avais je
n'avais pas ma meilleure forme physique
mais grâce à la foule où j'étais capable
de bien bien skier si vous avez des
questions je prêt à vibrer avec ce juste
une question sur la cause aujourd'hui
est ce que vous étiez par les bolt 9 qui
toi pour établir une stratégie non ce
serait pour non non je parle j'ai jamais
parlé de ma vie à gauche n'a fait que je
peux plus parler aujourd'hui
mais
était en fête pour ceux qui ont vu les
rendre déjà partir de vendredi pour ceux
qui suivent le skite ébauche la ville
prend il est en avant tout le talent
fait c'est comme pour moi c'était comme
faut juste que j'essaie de le suivre
normalement d'un départ comme
aujourd'hui quand tu es deux gommes en
est lui qui est en avant pendant le
coupe de kilomètres ou 2 go ou les chez
les filles c'est comme ça aussi
après une coupe de kilomètres l'udc est
d'en avants mas mrs pour dire le faire
fait le travail doit aussi mais c'est
arrivé une fois le pendant la course lui
c'est vraiment c'est pour ça qu'à
l'arrivée moi j'ai pointé jeudi state
oil plus fort aujourd'hui l'oeil était
vraiment il était plus fort que moi
clairement puis plus fort que les bots
aussi mais lorsqu'ils font ces pôles
plus fort qui gagne tout le temps c'est
c'est une des beautés du sport c'est
pour ça que moi j'ai eu des podiums dans
ma carrière parce que je pense pas que
j'aie jamais été le plus fort mais des
fois je capable d'emmener grâce à la
stratégie l'équipement la technique
d'autre chose fait que pour la suite des
choses pour toi de quelle façon tu vas
rester impliqué lorsqu'il te font si tu
veux rester un prix évidemment mais pour
l'instant il n'y a pas encore de plan
concret le juste pas que le téléphone
portable sonner y a pas de plan concret
encore mais c'est certain j'ai parlé
avec louise cgem recettes appliquées et
surtout au niveau de d'essayer de
trouver des idées comment changer un peu
le moule casser le moule du
développement surtout pu y avoir de
nouvelles idées parce que je ne me vois
pas devenir entraîneur
moi j'ai toujours pensé qu'il ya des
exceptions c'est certain comme toute
chose dans la vie mais je pense pas
qu'un athlète qui a atteint un très haut
niveau dans son sport je pense pas que
c'est la meilleure personne pour devenir
un entraîneur je pense est mieux d fois
quelqu'un que j'ai fait du sport oui
mais qui en a bavé un peu plus que ce
qu'ils sont rendus au top avec moi je me
vois pas je ne vois pas donner
entraînant je veux je veux terminer mes
études des endroits et tout mais mais
je vais rester un pic était juste au
mont sainte anne dans mon club c'est
certain je vais pouvoir aller rencontrer
les jeunes métier la raison pourquoi je
prends ma retraite ou cissé s'est
beaucoup due au voyagement que j'ai fait
depuis plusieurs plusieurs années plus
d'une décennie maintenant je me rends
barclay pas d'un autre chose qui me fait
voyager qui fait en sorte que je vais
être parti de la maison haute en cavale
est une autre question
alex oui sud laisse un gros héritage à
porter comment est ce que tu vois que
les jeunes qui ont côtoyé vont pouvoir
relever ce défi ni métier je pense que
au début
la preuve la chose la plus important
c'est de croire de juste de croire en
soi mais croire que c'est possible
d'atteindre un haut niveau dans notre
sport dans l'impôt dans ce dans quoi les
choses qu'on entreprend dans la vie je
pense que au moins pour ce mois j'ai pu
leur montrer que c'est possible vraiment
même en tant que les canadiens québécois
rrq est que nord-américains que même si
le circuit de la coupe du monde se
trouvent en europe à 99% du temps que
c'est les pays scandinaves les européens
que sont les meilleurs au monde oui mais
il ya quand même des canadiens qui sont
qui sont capables de tirer leur épingle
du jeu donc juste se montrer que c'est
possible mais pas juste moi là dedans
alors il ya eu des venues et beckie
scott avait on a eu beaucoup beaucoup
mais montrer que quand même c'est
possible puis après ben c'est sûr ça ça
prend beaucoup de travail ça prend une
dose de talent la base mais je pense
qu'on en a beaucoup qui ont du talent au
canada faut juste que le système de
développement soient encore mieux qu'il
l'est en ce moment mais moi je pense en
ce que j'espère que le plus gros laids
que j'essaie juste leur montrer que
c'est possible d'atteindre ce niveau là
six des dix vraiment corps et âme à
chaque jour c'est le ski de fond c'est
un sport c'est un mode de vie finalement
atteint chaque sport d'endurance je
pense qu'un mode de vie spock ans fait
stop sorte amendes que tu aies pu un
athlète le thé faut que tu
couche tous marchent bien être papa tu
peux pas te promener l'après-midi aller
magasiner il faut que tu te reposes des
gens mais tout fait que c'est vraiment
24 heures sur 24
donc je pense qu'il y en a qui ont vu
comme moi j'ai mené ma carrière à
l'entraînement partir du mois de mai
même et leur montrer que c'est possible
si tu fais les bonnes choses à tous les
jours pendant quatre cinq six ans doit
peut-être une chance d'être en haut au
plus haut niveau ce qui est en question
est ce que tu as eu la carrière que tu
rêves commencer oui bon honnêtement
c'est quand j'étais jeune je t'ai pas le
meilleur je t'aime pas dans les
meilleurs au québec le sait moins de
running gag chez moi je suis ça de la
famille que jamais gagné de médaille aux
jeux du québec mes deux soeurs mes deux
parents l'ont filmé moi j'ai jamais
réussi à le faire fait que je t'ai pas
je rêve était comme plusieurs petits
culs rêve d'aller aux jeux olympiques
mais tu sais quand je t'ai tout jeune
c'était pas si c'était comme un rêve
parce que je rêvais mais c'était pas
très concret dans ma tête je dirais que
c'est un maniaque ans a commencé à
débloquer c'est comme aller tellement
vite mais si ça passait comme d'un rêve
presque est vraiment un rêve lointain
presque inaccessible quelques années
plus tard je me trouvais une deux trois
fois par année sur le podium de la coupe
du monde fait que ces trois années là
c'est allé tellement vite que c'est
comme je pense que je me suis rendu plus
loin que ce que j'aurais pu penser quand
j'étais plus jeune
c'est certainement parce que j'y
arrivais mais je peux pas dire que j'y
croyais vraiment temps que ce que
j'allais me rendre à ce niveau là où tu
vois
c'est dans l'histoire du sport au canada
où tu te vois mais je pense pas que
c'est moi la meilleure personne pour
décider seul métier tout plein standard
l'otite il ya eu on a des filles on a
trois filles ont gagné des médailles
olympiques
donc c'est ça c'est une chose que moi
j'ai jamais réussi à faire mais sinon au
niveau des dix tous les autres grands
rendez vous tuer autant tour de ski et
les mondiaux j'ai toujours réussi à
répondre présent la fecq
je pense qu'on est plusieurs lots qui
ont eu des des bonnes carrières en
commençant par mon père après une
béquille sarah chang joie et des veines
puis moi donc tu es on est on est
peut-être 5,6 là dedans mais je pense
pas que suis la meilleure personne pour
pour mettre un ordre de la donne
salut alex tu peux tu me dire quel
message que tu veux laisser aux gens
chez eux c'est premièrement les
remercier du support qui m'ont donné
depuis que je suis tout petit moi je
suis là mais j'ai grandi là bas j'étais
à l'école primaire secondaire sur la
côte de beaupré
mais en même temps leur applique son on
est chanceux de vivre d'andorre dans
sept ans se compter l'eau du québec
tisser c'est exceptionnel qu'on a en
termes de nature on est prêts on est à
proximité de la ville de québec
c'est une grande part fait comme ville à
québec mais on est juste un petit peu en
retrait on a le mont sainte anne en a
tout plein de choses on à la nature m à
proximité mais en même temps on peut
arriver un aéroport international en 35
minutes mais je pense qu on est choyé de
vivre dans ce milieu là mais surtout
merci de m'avoir supporté depuis mai
mais mes premiers pas de ski alex si tu
avais été norvégien est ce que les
choses auraient été beaucoup de serre
c'est difficile à dire je pense que
j'aurais eu peut-être des propos tête
j'aurais eu un plus d'athlètes d'un
niveau similaire que moi à chaque
échelon non développement pour me
pousser à l'entraînement surtout
donc ça aurait peut-être fait en sorte
que peut-être j'aurais pu être un skieur
qui va plus vite mais le revers de la
médaille c'est qu'en norvège en a
tellement des skieurs qui vont vite que
quand c'est un peu prendre une décision
les coachs pour faire une sélection dans
les grands championnats
faut qu'il y en a plusieurs qui vont
très vite qu'ils peuvent même pas
prendre le départ de la course tandis
que moi en tant que canadiens jetez un
oeil dessus j'étais assez vite pour
avoir le droit de faire toutes les
courses que je voulais moi je faisais
mon propre calendrier donc pour moi le
meilleur exemple c'est les mondiaux en
2013 à val di fiemme en italie
j'ai terminé troisième au sprint mais si
j'étais norvégien cette année là
j'aurais pas pris le départ du prime il
y avait dix norvégien sur la liste
internationale la fils qui était
meilleur que moi sur papier donc je leur
ai juste pas eu l'opportunité de faire
le sprint puissions notion continue même
en 2011 qu'on a gagné les mondiaux des
28 mois si on avait été norvégien je
pense pas qu il répliqué péter notter
garde de l'équipe pour me mettre dans
l'équipe dompter il ya plusieurs
opportunités que j'ai pu avoir que
j'aurais pu
si j'avais été norvégienne auxi comme
c'est vraiment dur cela dit c'est on
peut pas c'est j'aurais eu plus de
challenge à l'entraînement que ce qui
m'aurait probablement aidé à être
meilleur mais je ne sais pas si j'aurais
eu autant d'opportunités que j'ai eu en
tant canadiens alex on comprend que tu
prends ta retraite notamment parce que
tu t'ennuies ton monde en maillot
nantais la retraite est ce que tu veux
t'en du bit quelque chose de ton sur ce
circuit c'est certain c'est moi j'ai
vécu ma passion depuis que j'ai 16 ans
vraiment plein match un sport amateur
mais je les fais je les fais quand même
de façon professionnelle avec une équipe
professionnelle autour de moi je t'ai
comme le sens d'un petit monde
finalement là
le sens de tim alex si on veut ya
tellement de noms qui me prêt qui
prenait soin de moins qui prennent soin
de moi encore aujourd'hui et donc c'est
sûr que ça ça va être très difficile
pour moi de de retomber dans le monde
réel mais aussi puisque c'est peut-être
le plus gros challenge et les moments
que j'ai vécus en fin de semaine puis
plus tôt dans ma carrière les niveaux le
niveau d'intensité d'extase que tok hun
tatin un gros objectif
ça va difficile de recréer ça dans la
vie de tous les jours va falloir que que
je réajuste que je guette un peu mais
mes attentes
et même si chez qu'il ya des nouveaux
défis qui m'attendent qui devrait me
motive et puis si je réussi à atteindre
ses objectifs l'eau ça ça devrait me
donner de la satisfaction mais ça va pas
être autant d'émotions bio tendait
d'adrénaline que quand tu pars ce fils
de large et d'arriver comme aujourd'hui
comme il ya quatre heures c'est comme
tout laissé sa pièce puis finalement ça
c'était dans les trois meilleurs tu vas
être récompensé le podium et toute une
foule qui crie après toi depuis ça fait
4 heures de temps qui crie ton nom tu es
sabah difficile de revivre ça va juste
falloir que je réagisse mais mes
attentes donc ça c'est sûr ça va me
manquer mais c'est c'est vous arrange
magistrat louis have you done in english
mais je veux saluer dans une transe
magazine félicitations d'abord pour
votre victoire et votre trept
merveilleux votre carrière
on vous couvrez votre père depuis 90
votre père était sur la page couverture
de ski trikes tracks et vous cinq fois
des fois je blague qui est plus
populaire au québec je pense que je
connais la réponse maintenant en
débutant cette saison vous saviez que
vous allez prendre toute retraite a eu
une saison de hauts et de bas et après
oslo vous avez obtenu la cinquième place
de l'a54 vous saviez que vous allez
finir la saison en force ce que vous
pouvez vous imaginer ça la réponse non
en février début mars quand ce que je
m'attendais
de l'événement ici à québec je rêvais un
podium je croisais les doigts que ce
soit à sprint
mme ashton ou même le temps d'une
journée aujourd'hui de manière réaliste
c'est le maire que j'aurais pu espérer
étant donné les circonstances et la
saison que j'ai vécue alors non c'est au
delà de mes attentes et pour moi c'est
une cerise sur le sundae pour finir
comme ça pas de regrets j'en avais pas
avant mais c'est une belle façon de
terminer ma carrière dans le top 30 à 3
aujourd'hui même si c'est pas ça de
l'objectif mais c'est toujours bien de
gagner à la règle votre première
victoire en coupe du monde c'était la
coupe du monde canadienne j'avais à
emporter et qualifient pour les bucs à
quel point c'est important d'avoir des
coupes du monde au canada
je pense que voilà alex harvey qui met
fin à sa carrière à l'âge de 30 ans en
ayant participé yannick gourdon est avec
moi pour en parler en fin de semaine à
cette coupe du monde
à québec il a remporté deux médailles
des médailles d'argent donc une belle
feinte il disait la foule était là pour
justement l'encourager le saluer au sens
avait été difficile de demander un
meilleur résultat pour alex harvey en
termes deux derniers week-ends de course
pour lui de 20
parents amis famille les gens qu'ils de
son club se sont déplacés pour
l'encourager et d'aller chercher ses
victoires ses médailles deux fois le
podium sur la deuxième marche du podium
c'est vraiment exceptionnel pour lui
parce qu'on sait il n'a pas connu la
saison rêvé cette année c'était
difficile physiquement au niveau des
émotions également pour la première fois
depuis le début de sa carrière il a dit
je me suis retrouvé tout seul ses amis
c'est c'est les gens avec lesquels ils
s'entraînent ce n'était plus avec lui de
vendre que chez a pris sa retraite
l'année dernière les badges sa peine
participer aux compétitions cette année
bref y avait c'était très différent
cette année alors de se rendre jusqu'à
québec et de pouvoir être à son meilleur
à québec ça c'est exceptionnel et ils
performent bien en fin de saison
habituellement ça historiquement parlant
c'est la quatrième fois là qui va
terminer deuxième au final de la coupe
du monde et ça c'est bien mais ça a été
une saison difficile d'être terminée sur
une note comme ça ça c'est merveilleux
et ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est
que c'est pas c'est pas une course là un
tour d'honneur
ils se battaient aujourd'hui main oui
contre deux des meilleurs présentement
lui prend sa retraite lui quitte le
sport lui dis-je trop vieux je suis
capable je suis plus mais il est en
train de se battre contre les deux
meilleurs de sa discipline
alors que ces deux-là temps d'aller
chercher le globe de cristal et ils sont
besoin de gagner pour aller chercher la
première position du classement général
de la saison
donc c'était pas un tour d'honneur
c'était vraiment une bataille puis il a
réussi à 30 ans à s'accrocher au
norvégien qu'il est beau finalement à
gagner et puis à bolt une oeuvre qui est
en dessous l'un des deux russes qui l'a
devancé à pyongyang aux jeux olympiques
donc vers mars et deux langues a jamais
parlé
donc il n'a jamais parlé parce que bon
on comprend aussi qu'il donne une
affinité plus naturel avec leur région
mais c'est ainsi l'occasion aussi de
revenir sur cette carrière spectaculaire
pour alex hervé deux fois champion du
monde individuellement et en équipe avec
de vente que cha il a aussi sa faut le
mentionner parce que il a terminé deux
fois sur le podium du classement général
de la coupe du monde qu'il a prouvé
qu'il était capable d'être le meilleur
sur une course mais il a aussi prouvé
qu'ils étaient constants sur une saison
et il a terminé donc deux fois sur le
podium 3e au classement général de la
coup rythme et il faut le rappeler c'est
le fondeur canadien le plus décoré de
l'histoire se fait en dehors des jeux
olympiques et jean marie lacroix
remporté 20 podiums en coupe du monde
deux fois donc champion du monde deux
fois au classement général de la coupe
du monde
il a un podium ou six autour de ce qui
vous savez cette compétition qui se
déroule dans trois pays en allemagne en
autriche en italie ce mémoire est bonne
bref c'est un peu comme le tour de
france en 6 ans chris mellas cette fois
c'est en ski de fond et puis il a
terminé troisième en 2018 et là quatre
podiums au final de la coupe du monde
donc c'est vraiment exceptionnel et
quand on mêle et ça c'est une feuille de
route qu on pourrait associer un
norvégien un russe un italien
c'est tout à fait normal il a le talent
il est bien entouré mais quand on met le
contexte canadien à travers tout ça il à
derb parlais tantôt le du revers de la
médaille c'est très intéressant parce
que lui d'aller chercher ces
résultats-là en devant s'exiler
près de la moitié de l'année depuis une
décennie de s'éloigner de sa famille et
aussi au niveau des entraînements sont
pas toujours évident et il parle c'est
ce qui n'a du financement des scouts
fond il ya plusieurs personnes qui ont
des très très bonne idée au niveau du
développement mais ça va prendre des
fonds pour ça puisqu'on va falloir être
patient cc des jeunes on en a dix qui
entraient très prometteur en ce moment
mais ils vont peut-être même pas se
qualifier pour les prochains jeux
olympiques puis si par magie se qualifie
c'est certain qu'ils seront pas là pour
jouer le podium
donc non la façon que le système
fonctionne c'est difficile
afin dé même pour chaque fédération
c'est difficile de faire un budget plus
15 ans avance parce que t'as aucune
prédiction vraiment de l'année qui suit
donc et non si c'est vraiment pas idéal
comme scénario c'est sûr que ça va
prendre des idées je pense que déjà pour
l'an prochain j'ai entendu qu'ils vont
avoir plus de camps d'entraînement mais
au canada pour couper pour que ça coûte
moins cher que quand on va en europe ou
aux états unis par exemple puis
peut-être être présents coupe du monde
mais pas toutes les épreuves de coupe du
monde sauve un peu d'argent alors pour
vraiment ciblé des épreuves plus clé
pour nos skieurs de développement mais
va falloir être créatifs parce que je
pense que c'est certain qu'il va avoir
moins de fonds l'eau cette année mais
mais j'espère que avec ce que nous
jeunes ont fait aux mondiaux juniors
entre autres cette année
supported open ou produits on peut voir
qu'il ya quand même un futur prometteur
même si pour dans une expectative de 17
ans maintenant là parce que moi je pense
vraiment que les jeux dans trois ans et
c'est trop tôt pour ces jeunes a levé
récemment le dopage fait encore partie
de ton sport es tu déçu que ce soit
encore le cas au moment de partir avec
les pressions quand même en union se
dirait que le bout de sa
ah ben non c'est décevant c'est certain
mais on dirait que les choses changent
pas de temps que finalement ça
s'applique à presque tout dans la vie tu
es moi c'est décevant mais c'est pas
surprenant pour moi tu es j'ai vraiment
eu la conviction toute ma carrière qu'il
y avait des tricheurs contre moi puisque
pour ça que je dis en début d'entrevue
dit que c'est pas le plus fort qui gagne
pas tout le temps le plus fort qui gagne
piquante dos tu es plus fort
physiquement mais qui peut de faire bac
pareil part du monde qui vont être mieux
techniquement mieux au niveau de la
stratégie de l'équipement donc ça reste
la beauté de mon sport mais je pense
qu'il y en a encore du dopage puis c'est
certain c'est décevant puis surtout ce
qu'on a vu à assez fertile de le voir
graphiquement comme ça c'est comme même
si j'étais moi je m'étais peut-être fait
une idée en lisant des livres c'est sur
tyler hamilton des choses comme ça qui
expliquait quand même ce moment sur
blanc sur papier commun qui se faisaient
des transfusions sanguines elle avait
des dunes gêné rappeler au tour de
france mais de le voir comme ça c'est ça
lève le coeur puis surtout mon devoir
pour moi ce qui m'avait choqué beaucoup
c'est de voir que c'est pas c'est pas
poli meilleurs au monde plus juste les
meilleurs au monde en titre qui de
foncer du monde presque en q3 en milieu
de peloton si on veut donc c'est encore
présent c'est certain c'est sûr c'est
décevant mais mais moi je suis pas
surpris d'être sur l'eau aucunement
merci beaucoup à l'est que j'aimerais
offrir le micro ce qui veut dire un
petit mot de la fin pour finir sur une
note plus positive mais juste pour
terminer c'est à vous tous les médias je
veux vraiment vous remercier sincèrement
parce que je considère que j'ai une très
très très belle couverture de presse
durant toute ma carrière c'est sûr
qu'avec le nom puis le parc que j'ai eu
avant moi ça ça m'a aidé mais si
honnêtement vous avez toujours écrit des
ddd très bon article qui fait des super
bon topo sur moi même même les fois
qu'il ya eu des moments plus difficiles
je pense entre autres à sotchi où on est
toutes les deux les déboires qu'on a
connu c'est ça
j'ai vraiment l'impression que vous vous
êtes est toujours capable de rapporter
ça objectivement pipi de quand même me
faire bien paraître dans les médias dont
je vous remercie sincèrement parce que
c'est grâce à vous aussi au fil du temps
j'ai réussi à avoir c'est des bons
commanditaires à avoir confiant après
qu'on peut s'amener des fans aussi dans
les courses comme aujourd'hui
donc merci à vous tous puis on va se
croiser de l'eau coûte la lance et
j'imaginais merci beaucoup à toi puis au
nom de toute l'organisation
sollicitations pour en fin de semaine
mais aussi à toute ta carrière
merci alors donc alex harvey rien c'est
une c'est tout un set petrov termine
énorme c'est énorme
au niveau du sport du ski de fond et du
sport en général a de voir ce grand
athlète prendre sa retraite
officiellement on savait que ça s'en
venait mais une carrière remarquable et
beaucoup d'humilité beaucoup d'humilité
il a aussi beaucoup appris au cours de
sa carrière faisait référence à
l'événement sotchi où il avait critiqué
ouvertement le travail des facteurs mais
à ce moment là c'était pas selon lui une
critique des gens mais plutôt de la
situation mais ça avait été mal
interprétés dans les médias et puis il
avait reçu quand même un bon nombre de
critiques par rapport à ces commentaires
on l'avait traité de mauvais perdant de
ne pas être capable d'assumer lui même
la défaite
et puis à ce moment là il y avait un
déclic c'est la façon que je vais
m'adresser aux médias il faut que je
parle faut je pense à la réaction que ça
va créer
parce que c'est aussi là ils pratiquent
un sport qui n'est pas nécessairement
très connus ou et apprécié de tous
au niveau technique et au niveau du
partage par exemple n'ont jamais parlé
autant du fartage que les jeux
olympiques deux solutions soit
exactement
la petite pancarte rock et c'est la cire
bleus on est aujourd'hui en face ils
pourront faire pour deux heures on se
sait pas si c'est la bonne ou pas mais
il a aussi il a fait un travail
d'éducation remarquable alex harvey au
cours de sa carrière il nous a appris
beaucoup de choses
il a été très généreux dans ses propos
et j'ai l'impression qu'on n'a pas fini
de l'entendre on n'a pas fini de le voir
il va continuer parce que c'est vraiment
une passion chez lui le ski de fond et
on le voit on l'a constaté tout au long
de sa carrière
donc c'est vraiment et on a traité
important qui prend sa retraite qui sera
tirée par ses études en droit
alors qui sait peut-être conviendront le
vert a plaidé un jour exactement mais
avant je veux sont des précédents tomes
je m'en voudrais quand même de ne pas
saluer aussi la présence ou le départ
aujourd'hui de l'inde va juste parce
qu'on parle d'alex hervé on parle de
vendre que le chat qui ont été des
athlètes important pour le ski fond au
canada mais alex harvey n'était pas seul
et il l'a souvent dit ses coéquipiers
ont joué un rôle important et lamballe
geste qui lui aussi est âgé de 30 ans il
est originaire de toronto qui à 121
départ individuel en coupe du monde a
confirmé aujourd'hui le donc qu'il
prenait sa retraite c'était sa dernière
course donc lui aussi un podium en
carrière sur le circuit de la coupe du
monde mais il avait aussi gagné un
sprint par équipes avec alex harvey
merci de la brasse souligné merci
beaucoup